last time we visited with you it was
before the release of the mag I believe
last summer
how has the release of the film and its
success impacted your life Ken well it's
a you know it one answer would be not at
all but that would not really be a good
answer of fun you know a fun answer the
real answer is that it was disconcerting
to be validated for something that I
believed 22 years ago
and that I got a lot of other people to
believe 22 years ago including Doubleday
to the tune of two million dollars in
Disney to the tune of a million and new
line to the tune of a million plus and
so on and then it didn't happen and
suddenly all these years later it
happens and people go you must feel good
to be corroborated and I said yes I do
but the truth is it taught me the most
important lesson of all which I wrote
into it as they called the waiting room
if I have been waiting for the Meg to
happen or for any movie that I started
20 years ago to happen I probably would
be miserable if not suicidal but what
you do in the waiting room is you do
something else that that's how you
manage your time when you're waiting for
something that can be annoying and and a
burden and the what you have to do is
other things so what I did was 50 other
things and as a result 30 movies have
happened and hundreds of books and a new
publishing company and lots of other
things and yes it's satisfying to see
that the world endorses what Steve Elton
and I believed in 22 years ago that this
was you know a hugely popular subject
for a story and all the way along brave
people especially bill Avery who brought
it home and Lorenzo de Bona Ventura etc
other producers they made it happen too
just like guess what it shows among
other things is that don't waste time
hoping for something to happen do your
work and then put it out in the world
and let the world take care of it that's
one thing and then part of it is to
trust your the work that happened when
you know when you create this baby the
Meg in this case if it's a good baby it
will survive and it will show us muscles
when the time comes maybe it's been in
hiding for all these years but suddenly
it comes out and everybody knows it
that's great
but what that tells the artist I think
is to focus on what's at hand what's in
your workshop right now and do it well
and then don't worry about things you
can't control
focus on what you can control and I
guess that's my main feeling about it is
that we did a lot of work on the Meg at
the beginning we created its shape and
finally came out and it did great and am
I surprised
no I'm pleased but I'm not surprised
because I always believe it but I am so
glad I didn't hang my own personal
psychology on it because if I had done
that I had been you know locked up I
know it's like like like myself Steve
went on to write eight more books on
different subjects too and built another
career around his talent and he'll
continue doing that he's learned that
less than two that was disappointing
that it didn't come out back then well
it felt like it at the time but in
retrospect things are meant to be and I
always say to writers that I manage that
every project has its own clock and the
only problem is you can't see the clock
so what you do is you put in the works
the best you can and then you screw the
screws right you know the screws on the
cover and send it out into the world and
wish it well and turn to your next
project which hopefully you've done
before you finish this what project
and that's what that's what the creator
does he keep working on new projects so
this role didn't or perfectly God
creates another world maybe it's better
how often do you create do I create well
I'm always involved in at least two
creative projects
I've just finished three screenplays in
the last 12 months and one book that was
already published and a book that's
about to be published and I'm always and
never run out of creative things to do I
you know that's what keeps me going is
that creative juice that's why I I'm
drawn to helping other people with that
creative juice because I understand it
having spent my lifetime living it and
kind of analyzing it if you could be
remembered for one quote what would it
be your own quote oh my goodness I don't
know I I see my quotes on the internet
now honey I go well that's good that I
said that that's that's good I mean I I
think that I would probably hope to be
remembered for go for it and never give
up but neither of those are original my
mother is when he told me go for it all
the time and never give up you know was
Churchill that I think those are the
things that make a or you know creative
writer saying is sticking to those two
principles and that not don't let anyone
tell you that you can't do it or you
shouldn't do it or even you shouldn't do
it this way because if you have a clear
vision of where you're going you should
stick to that vision until you can't
anymore or just do it but Nike has yeah
just do it it's funny all these these
slogans I mean are universal they're not
just about the creative world they're
you know athletes are extremely creative
I mean
who break records are breaking them
because of their creativity and because
they too have understood their mind and
they too have this kind of managing
editor inside the mind that knows how to
hold off the world on one side and their
vision of it on another side people say
this particular high jump record can't
be broken but they believe it can and
maybe they believe it because they had a
dream that they did it or maybe they
believe it because they calculated you
know that if this and if that then I
could do it and maybe they just believe
that of sheer stubbornness but there
only one way to test a belief in the
creative world and at us to do it to
just do it and and every time it's
interesting people say this 3 minute
mile couldn't be run
you know this 2 minute mile whatever but
when somebody breaks the record like
that within the next 12 months it is
matched or broken by three other people
what does that tell you it tells you
that the role of creativity in human
life is to keep us moving forward as a
species it's the creative people who
have the vision to say this could be
done that hasn't been done before this
could be done better this could be done
different and we listen to that and we
there believe it or we don't believe it
but at the end of the day if it works
then suddenly everybody's doing it and
and the continent of reason is reshaped
by this eccentric little island vision
that it came out of the blue and
suddenly people believe it I mean nobody
would have known what to make of you
know tweets or Instagram or Facebook
just a few years ago 2008 I think is
when a lot of this really began or
earlier it's slightly earlier 2006 and
now it's hard to imagine the world
without it and that's how quickly the
continent gets changed by a creative
change you know the people looking at
art after Picasso can no longer
things the same way because he came
along and changed our way of seen and
that that's the beauty of being involved
in the creative world
you